hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
if you watched my last video on the
audioquest niagara 1200
ac conditioner i promised a more generic
approach to figuring out if
noise and distortion on in ac line
impacts the fidelity of our audio
equipment um
i wanted to do this project probably
three or four years ago
and uh went out and and bought a bunch
of equipment to do it and
just been busy ever since and i have not
used
i haven't tried to uh run this project
and uh
the results even surprised me a bit but
it's very unique work and i don't think
anybody else has done this
so um the heart of the system is is this
uh bnk precision 9801
it's about excuse me a 2200 device
it's very heavy and massive uh it's
actually sitting there
uh it's about this deep and it's got a
noisy fan
and what it does is that it takes the ac
from your mains outlet converts it to dc
and then regenerates it
using micropressure control very
accurate um
ac waveform that comes out of it it goes
up to uh 300 volt
amps which is roughly equivalent to
watts not quite 300 watts
so it's not suitable for powering large
devices but certainly good enough to
power a lot of source devices dags and
and you know headphone amps and
pre-amplifiers and so forth
um parallel to that there's another box
in there
um company ps audio they built this
20 30 years ago and built quite a fame
it's at the p300
it's also a massive box this big and
it's all heatsink it's just a giant
hunk of aluminum and heavy and it's
about 500 watts
um the reason it's very heavy is because
it doesn't have fan
um unlike my fancy instruments you can
only change the frequency with my
instrument i can change the voltage
change the frequency
and make bunch of other cool
measurements like power factor and other
things
um but it also produces uh you know ac
using similar scheme that i talked about
i've got a lot of requests on whether
these things work
so in this article i'll also show you
measurements of that device and
and quantify what it does
but anyway the goal is to see uh
you know what the impact of aca noise
and distortion is on audio equipment
and so far i've done this by measuring
power cords and measuring
ac conditioners and in every case
found zero difference and
as you'll see in a second i'm able to do
something with this
uh bnk precision 9801 that i can't do
with other devices in that i can turn
the tables around
and actually generate you know far more
noise distortion
and then we can see if there's an impact
on our devices or not
but first let's get familiar with a
little bit of the instrumentation and
what we're doing
um this is the ac mains measurements
using a specialized uh probe
where uh literally hook up two wires to
the ac mains
and i divide it down by 100 this device
does so that what comes out of it is
only 1.1 volts
instead of 118 volts and that makes it
safe to then feed the output to my audio
precision analyzer and not blow it up so
please don't do this test
unless you know what you're doing the
probe is also differential in nature
what that means is that any noise that
lands on it
if it's the same on on both cables it
doesn't get amplified and that's
important because
in our environment there's other sources
of of
ac noise and and what have you and you
want to really measure the device you're
measuring as opposed to
what could radiate onto it so it does
that also for us which is very nice and
my audio precision is differential input
and so it all matches and works really
well
as i've shown before my previous reviews
hc uh as fed to my house uh
has a fair amount of distortion and this
is uh
probably the norm or maybe a little
cleaner you could get worse than this
i doubt that you can get much cleaner
than this uh but at any rate the power
company doesn't owe you
uh clean power it's a miracle that gives
you something that looks like a sine
wave
uh on this thing uh but it's got enough
harmonic
and uh distortion and noise to actually
be something we can measure thc plus n
just like we measure an amplifier we can
measure our ac mains
it thinks it's got about 1.9 percent
worth of distortion of noise and we
convert that to cyanide
it's about 34 db uh you can see the
frequency
60 hertz plus a little fraction so it's
amazing that power can be distributed
with
such high accuracy all the way out here
so let's now measure the uh
um what comes out of the ps audio
p300 uh let's see if i can just get this
scroll a little bit yeah and uh now look
at what happens first of all a waveform
is
very smooth and clean we no longer can
see any distortion by just looking at
the time domain
scope output uh the reason for that is
that we see our
you know main power spike over here but
now look at that the storage harmonic
distortion and noise
it's far lower and to tune off
we go from 1.9 to just 0.08 percent so
quite a bit lower distortion and noise
and if we convert that to cyano that's
about
61 db so essentially this is a
power amplifier is what these things are
high voltage power amplifiers but 60
hertz is something that's in your music
and uh that's what your amplifier
actually does converts hc to dc
and then amplifies whatever frequency
you give them these things are a little
bit more specialized but essentially
this is like a
amplifier that has a sign out of 61 db
if i then uh measure the same thing but
this time with my uh
bk precision 9801 lab ac generator
i see a very similar result um at this
time to get a little bit more accuracy
in my frequency and voltage but that's
not critical
uh thd plus noise actually drops 2.05
percent from
previous 0.08 so it's as a spectrum it's
cleaner spectrum and cyanide is about 64
db
that said that's because it has less
harmonic distortion but it actually has
a little bit more rising noise in here
in the you know work could be audibly
more
concerning but really the two are are
one in the same
um for the rest of these tests i chose
to no longer use the uh
p 300 from ps audio is basically what my
lab generator does and then my lab
generator has a trick up this sleeve
that this one doesn't and you'll see
that in a second
but as a statement on what p300 does
it produces clean ac power so
regenerators do regenerate ac mains and
because they do it under their control
like a
power amplifier would they naturally can
have much more fidelity than your
power company miles and miles and miles
away sending you power
so let's get to the neat trick that the
my device can do
uh my uh lab ac generator can do
it for testing purposes it can simulate
what a dimmer output would look like
the way uh dimmers typically work is
that you had that uh
you know go down here we have our sine
wave in here that would normally go into
a light bulb and the light bulb converts
all this to
heat and light energy what they do is
that they let the sine wave go on
and then at certain point they truncate
they stop conducting
and they do it on each cycle so you can
program
depending on where you set the dimmer
you can program how much of that
waveform
is left alone what part of it is chopped
off
and you can see it in here i've and this
is programmable in the uh
9801 i just set it to a random 35
degrees so 35 out of 360 degrees
is said to have no output and that's
what this flattened section is
we see the waveform is somewhat deformed
also so it's his emulation is not
perfect but
you know in this case we want dirty
power and the dirtier the better
so there's a little bit of uh uh you
know step response and deformity over
here
produce incredible amount of of ac mains
distortion
our thc plus n now is shot up to 18
so way above our 1.8 percent and our
cyanide has dropped to just 15 db
so clearly we have both load of
uh noise and distortion now uh
pumping out of uh you know the ac output
of
of this generator so the question now is
you know can this make an impact on our
audio devices because now we've
exaggerated it a lot so before if the
effect was tiny maybe we couldn't
measure it
but now that we've hugely magnified the
problem to a point where nobody has a
power
distribution has this kind of distortion
at all
uh and yet we want to feed that into our
audio clip and see what happens they
survive it did they produce garbage do
they
do a good job so i start again with uh
sorry let me scroll back up
okay um i start with my tapping a90 uh
preamplifier
and feed at four volts and four volts
comes out
and measure noise and distortion and is
as usual produces extremely low
noise and distortion well well below
threshold of hearing
it's extremely clean by itself as i've
shown before and uh
you know that's a sign of a
well-designed device um
first i uh hook it up to the bnk
precision
with this much cleaner output so i
haven't used a dimmer mode yet remember
when i
the output of this bnk precision is much
cleaner than
my mains and power excuse me
and uh we see that the uh there's no
impact whatsoever
the whatever we saw 117 db cyanide 117
db cyanide so
this so going to the positive side
filtering more
didn't do us any good uh is the device
is just as good and we've seen this
before
where i've you know taken other devices
to
ac mains filtering and shown that they
make no difference
but now we can go the other direction
and feed that horrendous ac mains this
heavily distorted ac waveform with all
these harmonics and noise
let's feed that to it and see whether it
complies
not only does it not complain nothing
changes in it
not one hair is out of place cyanide is
still 117 db and change
same output same everything this device
does not care what you've done to it
and naturally so i'll explain a little
bit more why it doesn't care but
basically
we see that there's no impact whatsoever
so it doesn't care if you make the ac
cleaner or if you make it tons noisier
and more distorted it doesn't care now
when i do these things
sometimes people come back and say well
how about you know you test with a lousy
device
which is a weird question because why
would you get a
lousy device and then go spend you know
a thousand dollars or more on a
conditioner
take that money and buy a better device
but anyway i went looking around for a
lousy device and
being who i am and the kind of products
i get usually i used the buyer to test
i don't have a lot of lousy products 99
of what i have
is extremely good but i had bought this
um
deck from uh
i shouldn't say i bought it i bid on it
that our audiophile society we had an
option to fund
the activities of audiophile society and
remember i donated the stack it's called
the sigma dac
california audio labs it actually has a
tube in the back
and i hadn't tested it since i
bought it uh yeah about a year and a
half ago a year ago
and so i thought well i'll pull it up
and you know likely has
poor performance and actually not too
bad
i uh hooked it up with my generic ac
mains and has a sign out of 81.
state of the art is 120 123 db so it's
not statute obviously
we would give it a very poor rating now
but certainly not broken 81 db
quite respectable i uh
then fitted the very clean ac source
instead of the
straight you know mains input and it
made no difference
why because the problem is in harmonic
distortion that is generating up here
it has nothing to do with mains and
whatever problems it has in mains
didn't improve you know these are power
supply issues that it has
and it has them whether you clean them
up or not is
sort of internal problem to the design
so it made no difference whatsoever um
at this point i was going to turn on
that dimmer emulation in the
my lab generator but as soon as i wanted
to go do that
this thing started to do crazy things
where the noise floor started to fly up
and down by itself
and the sign ad was just jumping from 30
40 up to 80 and then back down
i didn't have time to fix it so i uh by
the way was doing that on any ac power i
went back to the mains one it made no
difference just
decided that it was time for it to not
work uh i don't know if tubes combat in
there or capacitors or something but
anyway uh desperate i went walking
around to see if i have anything else
and i had this luxe g uh p20 uh
headphone amplifier um and it's got
a couple of tubes on it cute little
thing i had bought this year and a half
two years ago to test
and i had not unpacked it so i decided
hey when we unpack it and
you know test this one with it
so once again we start with the generic
ac and
we see that yep it has a lot of mains
hum coming in
and but it's real problem are these
massive
harmonic distortion spikes they're you
know bringing a sign out down to 66 db
or so so it's it's
you know this this thing's definitely
low performance so
i'm talking 66 db versus 120 db
in my other device and i hook it up to
the cleaner source with 98.01
and does it do anything not a single
thing
66 db before 66 60 we now
absolutely makes no difference no
improvements whatsoever
uh could not use the help but let's go
in reverse let's pump that distorted
dimmer waveform
ac into it and see what happens once
again
no change whatsoever the dirtiest
the ac feed you could ever think of i'm
pumping into this device
it doesn't care why don't these things
care i mean
intuitively you think the nicer the
ingredients that go in the
dish the butter should taste and if you
clean up the ac surely that contributes
the reason they don't care is because
these devices operate on dc which means
the first thing they do
is rectify the ac and filter it to get
dc
and that act of converting and
rectifying things to
dc by definition means you're getting
rid of ac components
so the wiggliness of this dimmer
you know waveform it's all gone it's dc
if you look at it it's basically a line
yes it'll have some low level noise in
it and ripple and what have you and
that's what's showing
up uh in here but
that's basically due to the design of
the device excuse me
um shouldn't have drank coke before to
the video
um at any rate uh so when you convert
things to dc
uh you know these problems just
naturally filter away here
we're not experiencing the ac mains
we're experiencing it
after it's been converted do you see and
that the sea then powers the circuit
and by the way a lot of circuits have
feedback and
other mechanism in them that makes them
reject power supply noise
and when you you're sort of at the wrong
end of this trying to optimize things
you're just not able to cause any change
downstream
so we have a very unique set of results
over here
uh in that we went all out produced the
world's dirtiest
you know most miserable waveform and it
made no difference so if that can't make
a difference
certainly shaving off a little bit of
distortion and noise from your ac veins
is not going to do anything
and by the way the only thing that can
shave off properly
those distortion noise are these
regenerators which are extremely
inefficient
suck up a ton of power but there's just
no reason to use them
you know i i use mine as an instrument
to troubleshoot things but
even though i have both of them they're
never powered on hooked up to any
audio equipment that i use so
uh you know we could be testing a
thousand other devices
and maybe one or two of them will make a
difference but
yeah that's not the point if these
things wanted to make a difference
when i made the ac so much worse
one of these three should have done
something should have shown at least one
percent change
we have we don't even have 0.01 percent
change there's just the devices don't
care
they shouldn't care thankfully no
engineer designs a piece of audio
equipment thinking
hey i'm going to have clean ac power to
feed them
no we're not going to want to you know
feed cleaning
you know we don't have clean ac by
definition we assume that it's not clean
and we filter clean it up one note if
you go to the thread in here
quickly got a secondary branch where a
lot of people try to defend
boxes that clean up ac for other reasons
they said well if you have
real noise that's causing glitches and
pops and hum
or whatever physically on the
transformer or in the output of your
machine
such devices may do some good fine but
i don't see people buying audio purpose
you know mains uh reconditioned
regenerates for that reason
uh just about everybody buys them
because they think they'll take the
fidelity of their system from here to
there
and i'm here to tell you you go from
here
to the same place all that happens is
that your
bank account goes down you're wasting
more power
more stuff sitting in between and by the
way anytime you have another box with
another power supply you could create
more ground loops
it's just the weight laws and
electronics work so
don't assume that just adding these
things that can have no negative
consequence they could have negative
consequence
so if you know what you're doing and you
have some real mains issues
sure you know analyze it understand it
go get whatever
i'm strictly addressing fidelity
improvements
and the you know tons of companies now
go sell these products to
make it audio equipment sound better and
i'm here to tell you that
i can't find any evidence that they do
anything and
devices according to both engineering
management measurements and everything
we know
you know there's no there there on these
devices
so hopefully you found this useful and
i'll see you in a future video bye-bye